these are the scenes tonight in the
heart of the French capital
French Riot police being pelted with
cobblestones responding with tear gas
and water cannon
[Music]
La Place de la Concorde not living up to
its name
in France you meddle with a retirement
age at your peril as president macron is
learning to his cost try to make the
French wait another two years for
retirement has produced a furious
reaction
bringing thousands out onto the streets
protesting across the river from the
French National Assembly
[Music]
inside
pandemonium
MPS were in a Rowdy mood as the Prime
Minister walked to the podium
jeering her and waving signs against the
plans to change the retirement age
and singing the national anthem
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
fought to be heard as she announced the
government would be forcing the changes
through Parliament without a vote
the government has for now Advance its
controversial plans but at a huge cost
and expose their enormous unpopularity
giving a boost to opposition politicians
like Far Right leader Marine Le Pen it's
an acknowledgment of total failure for
Emmanuel macron because it's his reform
he is the one who carried it it was even
the only one he defended during the
presidential campaign so it's his
personal failure
France has for weeks now been living
through strikes rubbish has been left to
rot uncollected on the streets and a
huge protests have gathered momentum
that unrest now looks likely to
intensify Dominic wagorn Sky News